bueno eh reconocer que hay un problema
de Salud Mental no es difícil
lo difícil es hacer tomar políticas este
llevar adelante políticas para encararlo
en durante la pandemia efectivamente
la crisis de Salud Mental llegó a tal
punto que se empezó a hablar de pandemia
de Salud Mental esa es una palabra que
no aceptaba mucho este que se dijera
pero realmente era así era muy notorio
todos lo sentíamos tuvimos todos una
crisis de Salud Mental en ese momento
empecé especialmente Cuando comenzó la
pandemia el confinamiento de modo que no
es difícil reconocerlo lo difícil es
tomar acciones para evitarlo para
subsanarlo para encararlo esto es lo
difícil pero se ha hecho mucho en la
pandemia gracias a enorme cantidad de
voluntarios yo misma estuve al frente de
una red solidaria que Atendió 2000 en
una institución como la que usted
mencionó yo era presidente en ese
momento 200 consultas se hacen
normalmente por año ese año hubo 2000
consultas telefónicamente el acceso al
teléfono y el uso de los medios
virtuales para para ayudar a la gente
realmente fue algo que fue muy útil este
y debería seguir implementándose doctora
ahora Cuáles son los principales
problemas que afectan la respuesta a los
problemas de salud mental
la respuesta los problemas de Salud
Mental es presupuesto y conciencia
políticas de Salud Mental los gobiernos
tienen que tomar conciencia de que la
Salud Mental es un problema grave igual
que la salud física que es todo una
misma un mismo problema él ya hace
muchos años que se habla de esa luz
psicofísica y este y tomar conciencia de
eso y acciones para eso necesitan
primero políticas y segundo presupuesto
la Salud Mental en general está en manos
de enorme cantidad de personas que
trabajan solidariamente que trabajan
gratuitamente nuestro país hay
muchísimos psicólogos que asisten a
pacientes durante todos los días de en
hospitales sin cobrar y esto es algo que
bueno se sostiene gracias a las personas
más que las políticas encaradas por los
gobiernos y sobre todo también el
estigma y la discriminación no que por
ejemplo lo mencionaba la OMS sigue
siendo una barrera para la inclusión
social y el acceso a la atención
adecuada Cómo combatir problemas con la
educación con educación y con conciencia
de que todos tenemos problemas de Salud
Mental no hay pacientes este y sino que
todos padecemos de alteraciones en la
Salud Mental mucho más en el cascrisis
como las que vivimos en donde hay crisis
sociales los que ustedes mencionaban
mencio de antes este siempre catástrofes
hay este guerras hay invasiones es decir
no es es muy difícil mantener el
equilibrio mental en las personas cuando
vivimos en un mundo tan convulsionado Y
entonces tenemos que atender a estos
problemas que se ocasionan también por
la misma convulsión en la que vivimos